what's going on guys this is rob and we
are here with devil's rain part three
now one thing i do want to clarify yes
we did do the superior tie-in the doctor
octopus tie-in for devil's reign
technically that one comes after number
three and so what we'll do in the
devil's reign playlist is we'll order it
in the chronological order and so we'll
adjust it so that it's issues one two
and three and then you start going into
the tie-ins um there is also a tie-in
for the x-men but literally nothing
happens like i don't even know why that
tie-in exists i think it's a three-part
series but the first issue is basically
wilson fisk trying to get rid of a tree
that exists out there in like one of the
parks because it's a portal to krakowa
and like ultimately the x-men have the
tree declared is like a you know
basically give it like political asylum
so that it can't be removed and then
like that's it like nothing happens
there's no fighting no nothing it's just
it's kind of pointless
so what this does here is is this one
initially picks up with ben riley now
remember ben reilly is the current
spider-man peter parker is currently out
of commission so ben riley basically
took over his place and of course the
police are being none too kind to ben
riley i mean obviously this is police
brutality but it's only really police
brutality if somebody's willing to do
something about it otherwise it's just
cops being dicks is really all it is and
so ben riley the funny thing about this
is like he doesn't really care right
like the cops are just are literally
just like beating him up i mean he's all
bruised and smashed like they smash his
face into a table and they're like
what's your name and he was like uh he's
like johnny spider johnny spider's my
name that kind of a thing but like he's
just not taking the cops seriously which
is the one thing as i understand it
really pisses off cops right and one of
the funny things that kind of happens
what we're told here is when it comes to
this idea of like civil wars and
different things along those lines one
of the big misconceptions is that a
civil war would ultimately boil down
between those in authority versus like
the citizenry but that's not true
because people's loyalties are not
necessarily tied to the jobs they work
and that's what you're seeing here that
yes there are a lot of people here who
are police officers pretty much
everybody in the precinct is a police
officer but they don't all agree with
wilson fisk and so one of the things
that's kind of established is that
they're not going to process ben
reilly's spider-man like they just
refuse to process him because they
believe that what wilson fisk is doing
is wrong when ben grimm and johnny storm
show up here ben grimm is one of these
interesting concepts because despite
being a member of the fantastic four ben
graham always kind of had this role
where he was as much street level as he
was the grander superhero community
right like the guy on yancey street and
that kind of a thing right he grew up as
like one of these new yorkers right he's
one of them and you would always see him
just as inclined to to basically stand
up for like this small guy on the street
as you would standing alongside the
fantastic four and like facing off
against galactus or something along
those lines and so that's why when he
shows up here and he's like look i know
you know a lot of you guys out there
don't agree with what wilson fisk is
doing but you guys don't agree with with
what's happening here you're not a big
fan of it and i can appreciate that
right because you know we're heroes we
know we're trying to do the right thing
and you see through what it is that
wilson fisk is doing even if these other
police officers here are unable to or
unwilling to but here's the rub we're
gonna get our friend because he saved
our lives multiple times and he saved
your life as well so we're gonna get our
friend and we're gonna leave now johnny
storm of course basically just like
melts the door and then ben grimm walks
through a wall and then you of course
have this cop and this this chick that's
with him you know that have their guns
drawn i mean what are they gonna do
right i mean with johnny storm just as
hot as he is if they fire off bullets
they would probably end up melting them
before they got to him and then with ben
graham the guy is basically bulletproof
so like i mean these cops can't really
do anything so they literally just pick
up ben riley and just leave right
because what are these cops gonna do and
so at that point you switch over to luke
cage now again i still say one of the
biggest problems that i have with
devil's reign right now is they skipped
the luke cage tie-in i would love to
have seen what the luke cage time was
about because what you're getting here
is basically the follow-up to the last
video that we did on the main devil's
reign event which is luke cage running
for mayor because it's one of these
things where in a lot of ways their
hands are tied i mean could they kidnap
wilson fisk and then just like fly him
into the sun and like that's the end of
wilson fest right he just disappears and
nobody knows where he went sure but if
they killed him they'd make him a martyr
and what that would do is it would
basically verify his cause the best way
to defeat wilson fisk is to get the
people on your side right the best way
to do that is not to like force the
citizenry into following your orders
it's to give them a reason to basically
ignore anybody who demonizes your
dictatorship but basically giving people
a reason to rally under you as opposed
to opposing you and so luke cage plays
this game pretty well insofar as saying
like you guys know who wilson fisk is
right i mean yes like you guys elected
him as mayor because he made a bunch of
grand promises and he saved you guys
during the whole secret empire event and
all that kind of stuff but behind all of
that you know who wilson fisk is you
know who's the kingpin of crime you know
he's got his hands in virtually
everything and you know this law is
unjust you know this law is a problem so
i as luke cage in running basically
against wilson fisk as mayor now what
this does is it puts luke cage in a
fantastic position because it basically
makes him untouchable the reason why is
because if for example luke cage were to
be found beaten up or assaulted then at
that point it's uh it's a felony right
you literally have a politician that is
basically trying to force another
politician out of the picture using
physical violence that would land wilson
fisk in prison for the rest of his life
and so luke cage basically cannot be
touched right it's one of those things
where it's like the guy's running for
mayor the difficult thing here is
getting people to agree with him and
that's what makes devil's reign so
interesting is because what you end up
doing is you basically switch over to uh
to a conversation between susan storm
and her lawyer and the cool thing about
this is that the the conversation
between the two is such that there are
legitimate concerns that when it comes
to the overall country in terms of
what's going on in the city of new york
they see it as a new york problem right
this is new york's issue new york is the
one that's dealing with like superheroes
causing all kinds of problems and
supervillains and the fights between the
two and collateral damage and all kinds
of right this is a new york issue the
concern here is that if these heroes are
not rounded up by the city of new york
right if they are not basically
imprisoned if this kind of insurgency if
you want to call it that is allowed to
continue suddenly it'll turn into other
people's problems because these people
in new york will retreat to other cities
and other states they'll go to new
jersey or they'll go to washington dc or
they'll go down to virginia in the
potomac or something along those lines
right but they'll basically start
bringing their problems to other
people's doorstep and so the biggest
concern here is that if this is not
contained in the city of new york it
could lead to federal law the return of
the superhuman registration act and of
course no one wants that
because even then with the superhuman
registration act as it was initially
done tony stark was able to curtail the
most extreme versions of the superhuman
registration act but in this instance
because of what's going on because of
how dangerous more recent events have
been that the result would be the
superhuman registration act wouldn't
really be able to be curtailed by
someone like tony stark and ultimately
it would be the worst possible scenario
for the superhero community and so
because of that the whole thing is we
have to basically find a way to keep
this contained luke cage is running for
mayor and in all honesty he stands the
best possible chance of being able to
end all of this following that you
switch over to zebedee kilgrave now
remember one of the things that had
happened here is that the the psychic
prism essentially allows wilson fisk to
harness the powers of zebedee kilgrave
and to use them and that's one of the
things that seems to be going on here
more so than that what's funny is
there's a conversation that goes on
between the two where wilson fisk kind
of talks about how he's doing this to
become mayor and all that kind of stuff
and kilgrave having been around the
block more than a few times is like no
you're full of crap wilson fest like
this is not about you becoming mayor or
anything along those lines this is all
based on a petty grudge daredevil did
something to you to make you forget who
he was and you want to hurt him back
that's all this is right that's
literally all it says you're targeting
him and everyone he cares about and
you're going through the legal system to
do it because it's a way that they
simply can't punch they can't beat up
the legal system they can't assault the
legal system or the political system is
the one thing they can't destroy because
basically you're taking the system that
they support and using it against them
and the funny thing here is when wilson
fisk is like how could you possibly know
this the response of kilgrave is because
i feel it too it's like a fog in your
brain i knew the identity of daredevil
and now i can't remember something
happened and where the initial thought
of kingpin is wait are you the one who
did this to me the response of killgrave
is no no no but somebody used my powers
to do it it's a more diluted form of my
powers but it's my powers nonetheless
it's my kids somebody used the purple
children to do this to you and me to
make us forget the identity of daredevil
and so following that where kingpin
basically goes on a mission to capture
the purple children the kids of the
purple man you actually switch over to
what what's really left of the avengers
you got iron man you got she-hulk
captain america daredevil and so on and
they're all kind of having this
conversation over what it is that
they're going to do with everything
that's going on here right like i mean
do they find some way to take out wilson
fisk that's one of the discussions
that's on the table the other problem
here is that for luke cage the polls are
not looking very good that what it looks
like is that wilson fisk has
successfully managed to basically
compartmentalize and control fear in
such a way to where the citizens of new
york are actually afraid of what life
would be like if they went back to the
way things were before superheroes doing
the best they can facing off against
super villains but in all in all
operating with impunity but in the
middle of all this suddenly jessica
jones chimes in and is like like when
all the heroes are arguing and debating
with each other she's like something
something's not right right something
feels wrong here something's off she's
like wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute no this is the purple man this is
the power of the purple man and when the
question's asked like no no no like you
know how do you how do you know that i
mean one when jessica jones comes along
and says the purple man's involved you
don't really argue right i mean her
history is directly intertwined with
zebedee kilgrave no one knows kilgrave
better than jessica jones does but she
also understands the nature of its
powers and how it feels to be influenced
by his powers and she's like it's subtle
i can feel it but it's subtle the whole
city hasn't descended into madness but
fisk is somehow or another using the
powers of the purple man to influence
people not control them right it'd be
different if he was like i'm going to
use my powers and everyone's going to go
to the polls and vote for me versus
using powers to influence fear it's
subtle and it's small and it's a genius
stroke and that's when daredevil steps
in and says yes like this has to be
wilson fisk captain america is a little
uncertain right steve rogers is like i
mean okay look we can go in and try to
take out wilson fisk but here's the
problem if we're wrong right if we are
wrong here the whole thing will blow up
in our face we'll be the bad guys right
we'll be vilified any support that we
have in the public will be gone and at
the end of the day what we're doing
requires public support our ability to
function as superheroes lives and dies
based on whether or not the general
public supports us if we attack the
mayor of new york who is out there right
now telling the public that we are
dangerous and it turns out that we're
wrong that he has nothing to do with
purple man and none of this is the case
it's game over that's the end of it but
the the idea of daredevil remaining
steadfast is no it is wilson fisk and
notice this one of the things that kind
of goes on here is like we got to take
him out right like we have to we have to
basically take this guy out we're going
to remove him from office and when the
question is asked like are we really
entertaining the idea of killing wilson
fisk or like disappearing him or
something like that the response of
daredevil is that's how it is when
you're an anti-hero right we do the
things that superheroes just can't bring
themselves to do captain america is
great in everything but you can't rely
on captain america for this right his
moral compass is too strong or whatever
the case is it's our job as anti-heroes
what we have here is a clear and present
danger in the form of wilson fisk the
mayor of new york the only way to fix
this is to get rid of them now the funny
thing about this is that they're not the
only ones that have tried to launch an
attack on wilson fisk there is a winter
soldier tie-in to devil's reign which is
weird to see them just arbitrarily
pulling bucky barnes out of nowhere
right and then just like launching a
one-shot with him i haven't had a chance
to read it yet i want to i have no idea
if it's good or not that's one of the
things about winter soldier man
sometimes the comics are great and other
times they're terrible it really depends
there is no medium there but i do want
to check it out but regardless because
of what had gone on with the winter
soldier and all that kind of stuff the
fact that city hall the penthouse of
wilson fisk right the mansion had all
basically become compromised there's
heightened levels of security here the
problem is that while they're basically
contemplating how they're going to take
out wilson fisk suddenly the forces of
otto octavius come flowing out right
like the auto incredible hulk and
wolverine and like ghost rider and those
guys all come flying out here now where
the auto ghost rider goes and attacks
the avengers he takes out iron man and
the statement of iron man is
particularly confusing here because he
says no stay away i did what you asked
what it looks like is iron man sold him
out that iron man told like literally
told kingpin and all them the avengers
are coming for you right like they're
coming right now and they're gonna
they're gonna try to take you out right
they're gonna try to remove like
forcefully remove you from office and
that's gonna be it at that point like
literally all these guys you know
they're they're standing like they're
facing off as best they can they're
holding their ground but then once
captain america gets over to iron man he
realizes it's not iron man it's
chameleon right the master of disguise
what a genius riding stroke right
chameleon was masquerading as iron man
and then basically set a trap once
captain america realizes what's going on
he was like avengers fall back and like
get out of here right we have to go
because we're gonna die here like if we
stay here they will kill us because what
this is by all standards of measurement
is an assassination attempt of a
political official that's how it's going
to look that's how it's going to be
depicted the avengers tried to
forcefully remove and or assassinate a
political official and so they're just
like like we can't be here like we can't
stay here now of course it's one of
those things where daredevil was like no
we can't let him get away but in the end
it's just like no we have to go and so
what you end up doing is switching over
to foggy nelson right he's the attorney
for luke cage the one that's basically
representing luke cage as far as his
desire to become mayor and so on and so
forth once he gets to the office he
makes a kind of offhanded remark of like
yeah man i oh my god i really should
have gone home and there's there's a
couple people in the office like yeah
you really should have here's a problem
you and that lady lawyer you have you're
loud and our boss doesn't like loud
people so our bosses decided you're
better off not being able to speak in
effect the kingpin has seemingly sent
henchmen to the lawyer of luke cage to
foggy nelson's office to basically
pummel him to silence him right it's
political sabotage this is getting
messy but oh my god do i love this with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this to an end god i love this story
it's so good thank you all for watching
and i will catch you all later
peace